Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my full Lord of the Rings rings of Power episode
7 video there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references so we'll break it all down I'm
doing videos for all the episodes be sure to
subscribe to get them and careful for spoilers
from the episode if you haven't seen it yet but
the biggest things this week obviously is the
official renaming of the Southlands 2 Mordor we
knew what was happening we're just kind of waiting
for someone to actually speak the name the funny
thing is though is that Adar doesn't actually
speak the name they use a title card reveal we
also saw the balrog of khazad dum for the first
time as well and turns out he's already awake like
they kept making all these references about king
during the third not wanting them to delve too
deeply referencing waking the balrog like you
want to avoid something really crazy happening in
the future which we knew would happen eventually
just because of the events of the later books
but surprise surprise turns out the balrog was
already awake and if it wasn't clear this is the
same balrog that was involved in the creation of
the mithril itself the balrogs are also maiar
just like Gandalf and Sauron like the celestial
being choir of angels just a different type of
maiar Gandalf and Sauron they were corrupted
by morgoth a long time ago and joined his army
basically it's like his dogs of war after his
defeat the ones that survived basically just
went into hibernation which is why the one in
khazad dum basically hibernated down here beneath
the mithril there isn't a big record about what
happened with the balrogs during the second age
so this is them just sort of adding this in for
the events of the show like it's not directly out
of the books they don't tell you exactly when the
balrog woke and started to kill all the dwarves
in khazad dum it just during the events of the
Lord of the Rings books in the Peter Jackson
movies Gandalf says at some point the dwarves
delved too deeply because of this mithril here
invoke the balrog and then it basically laid
war on them until they were all dead obviously
they're probably going to stretch that out over
the course of the series like five seasons however
long the show winds up running like they're not
going to kill all the dwarves off at the end of
season one but we will probably see the balrog
again in the season finale it'll be interesting
to see what they do with it during season two
if they're teasing it this soon that means that
things are going to be happening with it pretty
quickly one of the things that Sauron did early
on when they created Mordor was gather all evil
beings to himself so now the idea is that all the
people around the world that are still following
morgoth still believe in him will slowly make
their way to Mordor also really important to
note they announce that they're starting work
on season two right now they said it's going to
be way bigger way more action heavy than season
one was I think they fixed a lot of their pacing
issues but they did confirm that actual physical
Sauron in his fairer anatar form will be played
by an actor during season two on screen so like
we'll actually see Sauron walking around it won't
be like Sauron watch 2022 like anytime anybody
breathes at all people wonder if they're Sauron
even though during the Halbrand scene in this
episode there were even more song references like
every time he's in a scene there's some reference
to Sauron but the title of the episode is the
I which is a reference to the eye of Sauron
in Mordor because they officially rename it
to Mordor during the episode the actual opening
scene is the immediate aftermath of the eruption
of Mount Doom just blotting the sky out in the
Southlands with clouds covering everything in
Ash pretty much indefinitely until somebody comes
along and wants to terraform Mount Doom a little
bit well into the fourth age after Sauron is gone
they could probably eventually stop that Ash from
spewing into the sky but it would take a lot a
lot of work but the whole idea is that everything
here is covered in Ash giving it this reddish
cast to it the title of last week's episode
udun is the Elven word for this area inside Mordor
and in their language that also means hell so in
the episode it kind of looks like they are in hell
so to speak we get another one of Poppy's songs
a big part of tolkien's literature is that there
are a lot of songs through all the different books
the Harvard sees some of the collateral damage
from Mount Doom's eruption that's what all these
Boulders are very far away when they take it as
important of evil Rising that's a hundred percent
true because it's also a reference to Sauron
like the growing evil of Sauron the stranger is
whispering in quenya the language of the elves to
the tree like he's speaking to the tree trying to
use his magic to regenerate the area which takes
a little while but eventually it is successful and
I think this confirms that he's one of the maiar
a wizard probably we'll find out which one I know
there are lots of theories about which wizard he
could potentially be a lot of people think that
they're bending time and space to make it Gandalf
but I don't think that they're speeding up the
plot that much and it'll be somebody different
back at khazad dum elrond bargains with during
the third for access to the mithril in exchange
for supplies from the elves of Lindon for the
next 500 years and he's correct when he says he's
never broken a promise before because they kind of
gave him an out with Gil Gallard already knowing
about the mithril but when he says 500 years even
though that sounds like a long time because
they're speeding up the timeline of the show
so much I don't know if that's also meant to cross
over past the events of the war the last Alliance
when a lot of elves wind up dying or going back
to valinor and the gray Havens like there's still
elves around after the war of the last Alliance
in Lindon but it's vastly diminished from what
it is right now the book timeline for the second
age is way longer but like I said because they're
changing the timeline for the show it's a little
hard to compare when things happen in the books
to when things will happen on the show also side
note after gil galad the next king of Lindon winds
up being kurdan the shipwright he's the person
who's basically in charge of the gray Havens and
the ship that everyone uses to get to valinor
and they also confirmed that they're going to
be doing his character during season two so like
another really huge character we also hear about
galadriel's husband during the episode which
they'll also probably wind up doing on the show
in a future season because she says the last
she saw of him was before the war of Wrath and
she assumes that he's dead but he's probably
not because we know that he is alive later in
the timeline of the Peter Jackson movies also if
he didn't realize that she's basically elrond's
mother-in-law her daughter with her husband winds
up being elrond's wife and I think what they're
saying in this current timeline of the show is
that that hasn't happened yet she hasn't given
birth to her daughter yet and she hasn't gotten
married to elrond yet because elrons also never
spoken of having a wife and because the timeline
of the show is so different from the timeline of
the books I think they'll just change when her
daughter is eventually born like it'll be in
some later season elrond names himself half Elven
which is true he and his brother were born half
elves is his brother elrose chose to live life as
a human being founding numenor in elrond chose to
live life as an immortal elf so one of the other
jokes is that later in the timeline Aragorn is
basically like his distant distant distant cousin
many many times removed so him marrying Arwen is
them keeping it in the family so to speak even
though they're very very very distantly related
during the third mentions The Valor aule again
referencing the creation of the dwarves that is
the Valor who created the dwarves initially all of
his metaphors hear his speech about the rock the
fire their mortality as dwarves everything fading
to Ash eventually is meant to be a reference to
Mount Doom and Mordor in the episode because
of all the literal fire and Ash but it's also
a reference to the balrog of khazad dum that
eventually becomes their Doom so to speak most
of his speeches with his father about mithril
in all the episodes so far have been about not
tempting fate not delving too deeply the shadow
that will get them eventually burn them in the
mountain is basically a reference to the balrog
I think all their scenes together especially when
he gets really pissed off at him later in his
wife's speech at the end of the episode it's
just meant to reference that during the course
of the series during the fourth we'll eventually
choose to ignore his father's wisdom after he
dies at some point and becomes king of khazad
dum himself he'll be the one to say okay everybody
is fine to mind mithril again everybody open the
minds like the easiest way for him to get around
that problem is if his father dies obviously he
loves his father so it's not like he's going to
have him assassinated or anything like that but
I think they're just setting up that his father
dies and he does become the next king and that's
how they get the mithril to the elves when they
keep making metaphors about light and mithril
the whole idea is that the myth rule contains the
light of the silmarolls and thus some of the last
remaining light of the two trees and that's how
it's also able to reverse the blight the blight
isn't something from the books it's something
that they introduce for the show but it's meant
to show you morgoth and sauron's growing Darkness
over the Earth in very literally morgoth actually
poured his evil power into the Earth later in
morgas timeline before his final defeat he'd
actually poured too much of his power into the
Earth like he'd been dark in the Earth so to
speak with evil and eventually was trapped there
Sauron also has a similar type of problem later in
the timeline too he has all this power as a mire
but eventually in the downfall of numenor he winds
up losing a portion of it so he loses the ability
to change form and thereafter he just wears the
armor all the time so even Sauron morgoth Gandalf
these other Angelic beings have crazy levels of
power they do have a finite level of power we
see galadriel's basically given up at least
temporarily on the Southlands there's nothing they
can do about the environment now like I said maybe
long time in the future into the fourth age they
could do a little bit of terraforming with a lot
of magic and a lot of people working but the whole
idea is that they're moving the southlanders to
this safe area outside the influence of Mordor and
what's happened with Mount Doom that's all meant
to be an Easter egg for Gondor the actual place
they say they're going polar gear is the Eastern
Port Town that numenor sets up initially on Middle
Earth that eventually becomes the port town of
Gondor so like around this area they're going
to be creating the kingdom of Gondor eventually
when Galadriel says there were no Orcs when she
was Theo's age technically that's not true there
were Orcs but they all looked more like Adar
more Elvish than they slowly mutated over time
over the centuries to what their modern appearance
is but they're still the same basic race of what
they refer to as the darkened elves like elves
who were perverted by morgoth's darkness that
got started before the call of the Valar before
Galadriel was born they revealed that Muriel has
lost most of her vision there's no record in
the books about what happened later on in her
life here most of the books during this era are
focused on what farazon did and what happened with
the downfall of numenor not so much on her when
saddock is telling Meteor Man about navigating
through the Greenwood to find where he's going the
Greenwood is what they called merkwood before it
became merkwood which eventually we saw during The
Hobbit but the place that he's trying to find if
it wasn't clear is Mordor is the same place where
everybody is converging on basically at the end
of the episode The harfoots decide that they're
going to join him too and that's just a way to
keep them in the story during season two because
obviously the plot is moving towards that air area
when Galadriel is talking to Theo about how her
brother died he also asks if she's lost kin before
that's a reference to the Elven kin slang there
were multiple kinslangs most commonly associated
with the sons of feyenoir each time in their quest
to retake the silmarolls from morgoth there were
three separate ones all from the sons of feyenoor
when she starts talking about her missing husband
I think the idea is that when they reveal him
they'll just say that he was held captive by
some other Force like adar's forces or somewhere
else in the world and that's why he hasn't tried
to come back to Lindon yet Iran jokes with Duran
about letting him win their contest which a lot of
people actually thought after the scene just the
way they played it oh it seems kind of like he's
letting him win the whole thing with the dwarves
having secret names is a reference to the way
duren's folk choose their new kings in the books
they've kind of changed it a little bit for the
TV show but the whole idea is that Duran's folk
believe in reincarnation of their original Duran
so when they name a new king they renamed them to
Duran and it's like the person that they believed
to be The Reincarnation of the original one so
usually they don't introduce a new Duran until the
previous one died which is why it's weird that
there's two durians on the show right now but
the idea is that the name Duran is ceremonial so
when each new successor each new Reincarnation
of Jordan is found they renamed that dwarf to
Duran so the secret name would have been the
names that they were originally born with implying
that during the fourth had a different name when
he was born you also see the river on elrond's
shirt much more clearly here that's probably the
same river Syrian this on Gil galat's neck piece
and on adar's Armor so they have like all these
different elves that reference this particular
River it was like the main river running through
balerion during the first stage that was this
ancient Mighty city of the elves like the first
big city that they had on Middle Earth that wound
up sinking during the war with morgoth sort of
like a precursor to the sinking of numenor but
for different reasons a lot of areas around the
world sinking into the ocean that even though
there's this whole conflict with Dern and his
father over the mithral I think the idea is that
he'll die and during the fourth will become king
and that'll clear the issue but I think one of the
other reasons why he's so pissed off here when he
says the elronda is like a true brother to him is
is more so a brother than his biological brother
the king's other son because they do confirm later
in the episode that he does have a brother who
could potentially threaten his claim to the throne
getting very game of thronesy inside Lord of the
Rings that's like literally what's happening on
House of the Dragon right now they bring back
the evil looking women who seem like human Mages
following morgoth and Sauron technically everyone
who follows Sauron during this period would be
a worshiper of morgoth like even Sauron worships
morgoth the whole idea is that during this whole
period while morgoth had been defeated is that
saran was like their temporary boss until the
prophecy about morgoff's return eventually came
true like there's this long-running prophecy that
eventually he'll break free from his prison and
eventually return to Middle Earth but they do
confirm that they're magic users they seem like
they're human but I think what they're doing is
they're trying to set them up for a bigger Arc
during season two future Seasons like the whole
idea is that you have Sauron as the true big bad
but it is going to be appearing in his fair form
next season they're not going to play him like it
though like he'll be pretending to be their friend
and while that's happening they'll just have
somebody else be the antagonist like in the way
that Adar is one of the main antagonists of season
one I think this group of women will eventually
become bigger antagonists in future Seasons when
we go back to the new minorians camp here the tree
on the banners here is a reference to the white
tree of numenor is the same type of tree as the
two trees of valinor it just doesn't have the same
light that those two trees had and eventually the
same as the white Tree of Gondor obviously exactly
the same as the white Tree of Gondor the reason
why a reindeer bows to Galadriel even though he
comes from a different group of elves is mostly
out of respect for her High station like she's
far older than him and she was the leader of the
Elven northern armies so it'd be like a general
showing up in front of an officer they make a lot
of references about the Newman orians returning
with a greater Army and taking the southlanders
to a safe place just outside of Mordor like I said
that's just a reference to eventually what would
become Gondor when Muriel tells Galadriel no one
kneels that's also a reference to the Return of
the King when Aragorn Muriel's distant relative
great grandson many times removed of a lendil
says the same things to the hobbits after they
kill Sauron and like I mentioned earlier I think
one of the things things that will happen when
they go back to numenor and they find out that
she's blind is that pharah's own will try to use
that against her and use more of her Authority
and they'll just tease more the division between
the anti-valor sentiment on the island and
the faithful the faithful will be the ones
that return in force in future Seasons there's a
really funny Hobbit reference here too when Nori's
father says our foots don't slay dragons or dig
for Jewels that's a reference to the events of
The Hobbit very literally with smog in the eye of
the mountain the arkan Stone he's not wrong either
harfoots didn't do that Bilbo was a hobbit but
they are genetically related to the hobbits when
Galadriel basically says she's reporting things to
Gil Gala that's their way of roping in the elves
to the larger Mordor plot in season two because up
to this point gil galad had this big thing about
trying to avoid getting the elves involved in that
being more concerned with the mithril the forge
and the dying of their Inner Light their Immortal
Souls she also says she's taking halbrand back to
Lindon to be healed by The Elves and when she
says Fate has one more raft in store for them I
think that's meant to be another Sauron reference
because way later in the Peter Jackson movies when
she's talking to Frodo she also mentions the tides
of Fate talking about their fight against Sauron
so there's all these references to rafts in the
middle of the ocean and what happened with them
in the beginning of the season and a lot of it
has to do with her talk about Sauron also you
have the whole thing with Halbrand being taken to
the elves very literally Sauron tricking the elves
while he's in his anatar form so they really they
really want you to think that Halbrand might be
Saron but like I said it could all be a misdirect
we'll see we're still on Sauron watch right now
like literally any human being says anything on
the show people are like could this be Sauron
thankfully the showrunner did say that during
season two they'll have an actual actor portraying
Sauron specifically and it'll be his fair form
which is why I say the anatar version of Sauron
so it won't be like a big mystery during season
two it'll be like that guy right there that's
Sauron I already talked a little bit about the big
reveal at the end of the episode that the balrog
of khazad dum is already awake when they throw the
leaf through the shaft we'll see how much they do
with the balrog in the finale and what happens
with it in season two future Seasons because we
don't know a lot about what the bow frogs were up
to during this second age only that at some point
during the second age the balrog waged war against
the dwarves of kazadum and eventually wound up
killing them all the actual end of the episode is
the official renaming of the Southlands 2 Mordor
but like I said Adar doesn't actually speak the
words Mordor they use the title card when they're
showing you what it looks like now with Mount
Doom in the backdrop and also in the title card
here they shift from light to dark when revealing
the Mordor title to show you how it's literally
darkened the skies above Mordor so unless there's
some really big twist in the season one finale it
sounds like Adar might survive into season two
and just continue being one of the villains on
the show one of the many villains but if you
spotted any other Easter eggs and references
during the episode that I didn't talk about in the
video just write them Below in the comments in my
full episode 8 finale video we'll post next week
after they release it everyone click here for my
house of the Dragon episode 8 video and click here
for my full Marvel Werewolf By Night breakdown
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!